sergeant oh my god look
look at the sarge he's coming in he's
all decked out in camo he's got the hat
this is
as sergeant slaughter as i've ever seen
anybody be welcome
we're thank you we're here yes good to
have you man we were enjoying your uh
song before i forgot about the cobra
clutch
the cobra clutch do you still do that
live uh yeah
that's a fine song yeah did you i'm good
pleasure
i mean we uh we were listening you know
you forget that like
in the 80s rocking wrestling was a big
deal right
and you had the best deal out of all of
it because we were listening to your
song
the cobra clutch and all you had to do
was just say
the cobra clutch and some other schmuck
is singing the whole thing yeah
yeah and you still got top building yeah
i wrote i wrote the song because uh back
then when i first came into the wwe
uh it was a wwf and vince mcmahon's
father
was running it and he had me come in for
a tryout to do a promo with uh
with vince our boss of today and uh he
says there's anything i can do to help
you
get ready for your promo and i said i
went to my bags you get this cassette
tape out and i said could you play this
song and he goes well what is it i said
it's a ring for you
and he said you want me to play that
before you go out and i said yeah
i think he always you know helps uh get
things going
yeah he said well i never thought about
having music before
so he played it and that was the uh
start of
having uh music for entrances
i wanted to write my own music so i
wrote my own song and
yeah i'm not a very good singer so i had
that that's not true
you're a fine singer yeah you like it
were you in the marine corps you were in
the marine corps yes
yeah what years are you in uh i got out
in 74 168.
oh okay so you did six years so did you
go over to vietnam
tourists from vietnam yeah two tours
what did you do over there well
i would say basically just uh infantry
you know
just uh making sure all the uh the
grandstand uh
you know eight ball on us and keep them
online
were you messed up when you came back a
lot of people were like you know it took
a while to kind of make sure we never
really talked about it much
yeah it was something that uh we weren't
uh acknowledged as
you know being heroes or anything like
that yeah so we never talked about it
there's some blood bad
experiences and did a lot of things that
i normally wouldn't have done or
unless i was ordered to do it do you
when you see like the way people like
the
the u.s like you can see people felt bad
about that and then like when a desert
storm happened they treated the troops
properly when they came back and now
there's so much
pro-truth sentiment and support did you
resent that at all like what about us
and i did for a while but then uh you
know i got
you know with the wwe and we started you
know working with the military
and uh of course we do uh an event every
year
tribute to the troops so yeah it's it's
a way of uh
of me you know letting all that
hostility and anger out and
and put it toward a good good reason
yeah does it help to getting into
wrestling
like not too long after that and showing
up at these buildings in these arenas
where you do have adulation they're
cheering for you as a wrestler
but you're still getting that adulation
that you didn't get when you should have
well you know i
i you know i did start out as sergeant
slaughter i just went as my
myself you know and that was tough
because i was every time that red light
went on i was terrified i was shy kid
farm kid
and so uh i brought that was a nickname
sergeant slaughter the marine corps
never thought about because i was always
a hero wait they nicknamed you sergeant
slaughter in vietnam well you must have
been a [ __ ]
i can't tell you what i did over there
so anyway we
just never thought about using it
because i always played the hero
yeah when i i got done uh
uh i forget what i was doing but uh i
went to the house and i turned on the
television and all of a sudden i heard
the marine corps him and
there's a movie called the d.i with jack
webb in it
and i started watching them i said
that's a hell of a character for
you know a villain in professional
wrestling and uh you know he didn't use
any profanity
you know maggots scums pukes so i came
up with all kinds of different uh words
to use
you know so uh it uh panned out pretty
well for me that's like drill instructor
language right you maggot your scum
but they would use racial language i
don't think i don't know if they do
anymore
you know we can't do it uh you know
especially on television but
right yeah that would be a no-go no but
i mean like back then they would say
anything to you so yeah in the 60s
there was no hole in the back and and uh
it had a little brutal also
it did right physically brutal oh yeah
would you
do like a full metal jacket there's that
famous scene at the blanket party yes
did you ever see one of those
administrators yeah did you ever receive
one
brought back memories oh i've been in
one you've been in one yeah i'll be
participating yeah
what'd the guy do do you remember uh he
uh snuck the uh twinkies
into the uh oh it's just very so it
really was
like yeah
they made us do it so you uh
how long were you out of the military
when you got into wrestling
uh about uh six months oh so you went
right away yeah you're like i gotta get
this energy out of me where what can i
do with it i was actually on leave
and uh went to a pro wrestling training
camp up in
minnesota where i lived and a friend of
mine was a sports writer we used to
always go to the
pearlescent pro wrestling matches and uh
i went there and
i was the only one that didn't have a
camera or a microphone or
a notepad so they asked me to get into
the ring they said
do we have a volunteer to get into the
ring and make sure everybody thinks this
is real and all that and
of course being a di in the marines
you knew that volunteer that was a bad
word that meant you're in trouble
so i climbed in there and they of course
they made me uh yell uncle sam quite a
few times
and uh maybe tap out so i about to get
out and they said uh where are you going
i said well i don't see any reason to
stay in here any longer
yeah and you're taking advantage of me
oh is that right
well you think you do okay on your own i
said
better than i'm doing here you know do
what i'm doing so he said well get down
on all fours
i noticed about four or five of the
trainees that were
going through the camp or kids that
wrestled in high school
i beat them all the time
he got the coach told me to get down on
all fours in the wrestling position
and he yelled out rick you get on him
first and rick
i knew rick and i beat him all the time
and he he was rick flair of today
wow we grew up you know uh in pee wee
uh baseball and uh high school and
so i rick goes i got a bad shoulder
coach
get on him you know you guys grew up
together wow i pinned rick and
then they put capitaire on me and i
escaped from him and
and then it got to be uh an
embarrassment to them
so the uh other professional wrestler
billy robinson
uh he told me to get down on the force
and when i did he dropped his
shin on back to on the back of my ankle
tried to break my foot break my ankle
yeah just to kind of teach you a lesson
yeah
so i came up uh as i say the mud the
blood the beer and
got got him down and you know got him
taught him a lesson pretty oh yeah
wow and this is your first day i mean no
training no
that was still pretty good shape you
know yeah and uh so
they finally took me outside and uh the
main coach said uh where'd you learn to
fight like that
high school wrestling yeah where'd you
go to school i told him
he said oh yeah what's your name i told
the man he says
your last name remus your father's name
rudy i said yeah
he put the roof on my house my father
was a referee
yeah i know he told me you know so he
says well you're
you're uh you're ready for it but uh you
know i can't put you with this class
although he did pretty well
you're eight weeks ahead of you and i
said well i'm still in the marine corps
and that
can't just just leave yeah yeah so i
went home and told my dad about it and
he said well i think you gotta
give it some thought you know they were
farmers and
roofers and they didn't have the money
put away for college so
i thought well i'll just follow my
father's footsteps i went in the marine
corps followed him
went down to p.i and uh had the
opportunity and uh when i got out
i didn't re-enlist i just went right
into the training camp and
been doing whatever you look really good
like you know we i hadn't seen you in a
long time you look great i mean
you really appreciate that whatever you
do you [ __ ] look you look amazing i
went
i went to have a some minor back surgery
about a month ago
and i'm laying on this uh journey and
this guy comes in he's
uh i guess a nurse's eight or whatever
getting my blood pressure and everything
he keeps looking down at me and he goes
man whatever you're doing keep doing you
look great and i said
i'm in a damn hospital yeah
and it kept coming in you really look
great and uh
but it is pretty amazing like i don't
know if it's genetics or what it is
because you
i mean the stuff even after the marines
the stuff that you did
in wrestling first of all you wrestled
for a long time
terrible for the body yeah right and
some of the stuff you did even early on
like 1980 1981 you had a match with pat
patterson that was like a street fight
that was so brutal literally it's like
the only thing from 1981
that people in 2019 will still bring up
yeah it was called the alley fight
yeah and uh we were put into this match
by uh vince's father
and uh we you know got
everything ready to go there we built it
all up and
they sold out the not only the garden
but the forum
and i'm on my way to the forum watching
on closed circuit right yeah right
with the overflow yeah wow so uh
you know there was no rules you could
wear whatever you wanted no time limit
so i i'm on my way to the rain i had
ernie roth
uh as my manager i call him the general
and i looked at him and i said uh ernie
how does this match end and he goes
that's a good question
[Laughter]
there's no time left there's no referee
there was no referee in the in
in the in the match yeah so how do you
make the decision
we they i just were bleeding so bad that
they uh
he ran out and threw a towel a vince
mcmahon's father
told him he's gonna die he's not giving
up he's not stopping and i kept trying
to
crawl back into the ring how long was
the match uh it went about 20 minutes
well but it was just i mean it was
brutality it was it was a hardcore
before hardcore
yeah because in 1981 you weren't seeing
that stuff like you weren't seeing blood
everywhere and
and the the funniest part about it was
not that it was that funny but
uh vince's father wanted me to go to
japan like a week later
on a big tour and i didn't have a
passport so my wife was flying in from
minnesota to give me my birth
certificate
so we could go get a passport made as
soon as i hit that
uh top of that ring post i
i felt that burn you know you know if
you ever experienced it but
i could feel the the heat of the blood
running down my
my face and the first thing i thought
was how is she going to find me
what hospital in new york city will i be
you know laying in that chief can find
me yeah yeah no cell phones he's never
been to
new york he's gonna jump in a cabin was
supposed to meet me at a hotel
right and you're not going back to the
hotel
it's funny nobody would have thought at
that moment sergeant slaughter is
thinking about his wife
yeah flying in with him
and uh blood was just like pouring on my
hand and it was splashing
and that's all i thought about how is
she gonna find me did you guys realize
after that did you guys go we just did
something that people are going to talk
about for a long time or did you go that
was
that was tuesday moving on to the next
day when i when i saw the towel come
in i was really disappointed i didn't
want it to stop i wanted to keep going
whether how
we were going to stop it i didn't know
but it was a brilliant idea whoever
thought came up with it vince's father i
guess
but uh you could hear the roar people
it made sergeant slaughter that tough
ass
marine that everybody right knew was a
tough son of a [ __ ] you know he
he uh he didn't stop he didn't want to
give up and they threw the towel he
didn't
throw the towel in somebody else threw
the talon form but from that point on
i was like a god it was like you're made
you can't
nobody can beat the circle i mean was
there when they asked you to burn a flag
you didn't want to do it no and was it
with that was did they
okay with you saying no or was that a
battle back and forth well what happened
was i
just won the title from ultimate warrior
at the uh the ultimate puke i should say
the royal rumble in miami
uh florida and uh after
we won the title we had to do a lot of
promos and new promos because everything
changed
all the cards had to be changed and all
the
and i was uh having i was a champion and
he was the challenger so
so this by the way i mean just to set it
up a little bit this was a ballsy move
because you come back this is not 10
years removed
right from what we just talked about you
come back right you're uh
a bad guy right you're an iraqi
sympathizer yes
at a time when the u.s had a conflict
with iraq right but if i'm not mistaken
the night that you won the title and
said we're gonna go forward with this
was the same night that the u.s
announced this isn't
this isn't just a conflict we're at war
right and now and that's a much bigger
deal now you as a bad guy wrestler
are supporting the opposing force yeah
in a war you know
just kind of kind of uh fit right in
there you know
yeah made it even worse for me yeah i'm
sure it did because we were as i was
saying we were doing
new promos and uh gene oakland got
arrested so
he uh was doing promos and he had that
uh earpiece in
and all of a sudden he's doing a promo
and he goes wait a minute wait a minute
ladies and gentlemen i can't believe
what i'm hearing in my ear set
sergeant slaughter's behind the miami
arena burning the american flag and
and i'm sitting what did he just say
i'm burying the american flag wait a
minute wait a minute so i i hear it
he does it again i can't believe it i
can't believe it i walked right in front
of cameras i
went cut cut cut because it was
it wasn't live yes and uh vince comes
running out
that's why what's wrong i said i'm not
i'm not burning any american flag what
are you talking about i'm sitting right
here
yeah here's all we're just saying that
you did i said no we're not even saying
i did
i'm not that's the one yeah that's the
line that's going too far
that's the line you're going to lose
your sponsors you're going to lose your
television you're going to lose the
brilliance
plus you were over you had i'm sure
friends that were killed you know
in fight it just it went beyond people
that were there that night i mean
probably uh were there just uh by luck
that they didn't get killed
somewhere you know how difficult was
that for you so you go from about
january because the royal rumble's in
january wrestlemania is in april by the
way
april's coming up wrestlemania 35 will
be here at metlife stadium and tickets
are on sale for that
but this is at ticketmaster this is
wrestlemania 7 though
and you go from january to april more or
less
supporting iraq and every all the bad
guy
promos are about how you're gonna beat
hulk hogan and and
you're supporting iraq and um hulk hogan
supporting america
right and you're sitting there getting
death threats
right i mean people aren't looking at
this like oh bad guy wrestling right bad
guy promos they're like
you are a legitimate trader right it
wasn't sports entertainment yet
no right it was war right it was war
so you'd go out and people really hate
really hated you oh hey hated me did you
have to wear a bulletproof vest did you
say that i did i did not say that yeah i
did
yeah i uh i had just gotten out of gi
joe i went for six years with gi joe and
left the wwe
for the first uh wrestlemania i wasn't
there and i
believe it was supposed to be hogan and
i in the main event
wrestlemania one yeah number one so i
made this deal with uh
with hasbro and i thought vince would be
happy about it but he wasn't
he said i just signed with ljn and
that's a conflict of interest
i see so it wasn't necessary because the
gi joe cartoon was wrapped up in the toy
right sergeant slaughter gi joe toy was
what you signed for
right and now he's saying this is a
conflict to my business
he you know uh being the
the great leader he is he figured i'd
say okay
let's go you know go to wrestlemania and
while ljn and all that
but i said well you can only be a gi joe
once in your life
as far as a real live you know out of
the
gi joe cartoons and animated and
and action figures i was the first
living one you know
that's a pretty big deal yeah for sure
it is today yeah
so uh i declined i i said i'm i'm going
and he and he wasn't too happy about
that so do you regret it
uh no no i don't regret it i i i miss
those uh
being those first six wrestlemanias but
uh
in in the long run i'm glad i did it
and uh that's when i came back how long
was he upset for vince like what did did
that strain your relationship to the
point that there were years that went by
that he was like i don't want to talk to
each other i didn't even watch
wwe this is bad i was yeah i worked for
a couple of
independents started that for all the
independence of today
and i was making actually more money in
the independently than i was in wwe but
because you were gi joe at this point
too you're a much bigger celebrity and
by far the biggest names
all over the place yeah japan and
everywhere promoting gi joe
so when the contract came up uh vince
calls me i was watching the nascar race
one afternoon
kind of nodding off a little bit the
phone rings
hello uh sarge yep
vince oh hey vince you know there's only
one vince yeah but you haven't spoken to
him in years
no at this point so he said uh i had
sent him a
little note and handwritten note about
wrestlemania 6. i said that's
the greatest night i wasn't crazy about
the match hogan and
warrior the ultimate puke and comedian
but the production unbelievable
i said the cameras and oh i gave him the
whole thing
so he mentioned that right away so i got
your note appreciate that
i never got that type of thing it's
always usually it was a great match
great show but i never heard about the
production value production end of it so
he says uh i hear your
contracts up with g.i joe hasbro i said
funny you should know that you know yeah
he goes you ready to go back to work i
said yeah i
am so he said come on over to my house
tomorrow morning
got an idea for you so i tell my wife uh
and my daughter's that night i'm going
to
vince mcmahon's house we're going to
make g.i joe the real
real real real american hero you know
and vince is smart enough to know
that if i'm asking gi joe to be an iraqi
sympathizer this is an in-person
conversation we won't do this over the
phone
yeah so i get to his house go to the
library he's got this
thing all laid out of the la coliseum
104 000
seat capacity big screens all over the
place he says i want you and how going
to
sell this out and uh so that's great but
how are you going to make a hogan a
villain he goes
logan no i'm not making hogan a villain
i'll make you a villain i said
what what's your idea well you know
they're saddam hussein they
overtake a kuwait and you're not happy
with the country and
letting a little uh country like iraq
and
general saddam take over the world and
and
america is weak and you know blah blah
blah
so it's it's so it's it's sort of and
that's a that's a very vinsome
thing like it's very sort of
detail-oriented in the sense that he's
not saying
because i like iraq better than the u.s
it's a it's a bad guy it's a villain
saying no i like the u.s so much that
i'm disgusted
right and we need to be more like iraq
what's going on
plus he's looking at four thousand sure
right
now how did he convince you did you
would you like the idea immediately we
were like oh this sucks or what do you
like this is great you go from gi joe to
like saddam hussein's
i was kind of fabric flabbergasted
and i just i kind of just stood back and
i thought about it
and uh my funnest time in professional
wrestling
uh sports entertainment was being a
villain so
now here we go you know i'm gonna be uh
you know iraqi sympathizer
and he goes now go talk to your family
about it because it could be
pretty rough and i said okay of course
on the way home i
i said this is what i want to do next
morning breakfast
guess what that dad's gonna be on iraqi
and no more t.i joe and my wife goes
you're crazy you can't do that
you can get killed yeah i said well
let's see what happened she's
okay you're the you're the guy that runs
the table here so
we went after it and uh vince just said
i'll i'll let you
go and if you get too far over the line
i'll i'll pull you back
yeah he let me do whose idea was it to
wear the uh
the headdress or the headdress i wore
the uniform i got a
gentleman from minnesota who was a
manager there
name was billy white wolf he was an
indian wrestler but he was from iraq
went this college with saddam hussein
knew the language
had to escape you know the country
uh and uh he looked exactly like saddam
hussein you're talking about the dreaded
general adnan yeah
yeah he really did so sergeant slaughter
starts coming to the ring
like with an iraqi flag and everything
yeah and his manager
looks like a body double right of saddam
hussein yeah when he first came in to
show vince and i
he uh it was a hershey pennsylvania he
shows us his outfit he's got a little
handgun on the side of it
and i said oh whoa whoa no weapons no
weapons he's oh it's just a plastic
i said i don't care what it is you're
not wearing that to the ring don't give
anybody any
right ideas and vince says yeah you're
right you're right so so anyway we went
on this uh rampage and uh
just uh tore everything apart i i would
do uh
saddam's birthday i'd go to a bakery and
get a cake and then
get some candles and i have everybody
stand up and say happy birthday to
saddam
and then there was times when i was uh i
would say uh what
i want you all to stand up and give 10
seconds of silence to the brave iraqi
soldiers
in the uh overtake at kuwait because
today's veterans day in iraq
people wanted they were coming over the
railings and i'd always time it so my
opponent's music would hit and they
would be satisfied that this guy would
beat the hell out of me for a few
minutes
now as part of this just your confidence
in the ability to handle yourself
because
there is like you do have to exist
outside the arena
and these people are not separating like
oh that's not sergeant slaughter is just
a wrestling character like that's not
happening they hated you
yeah well it happened the first night on
the title after the
uh flag burning thing and they didn't
dare it we went to uh i went with my
agent uh
and we went to a denny's i think it was
and there's nobody in there three
o'clock in the morning yeah
no no service finally i asked the girl i
said
could you give her some service and she
kind of shook her head and she ran into
the kitchen here comes this burly guy
out of the kitchen he's got a spatula
and a little
navel cap on and white t-shirt walks
over the uh table and
he's got the spatula in his hand he
looks at my agent he goes
you can eat he's not and he points a
spatula at me
pulls up the sleeve of his uh t-shirt
and he's got the
united states marine corps emblem
tattooed on his arm
so i looked at my achiness i think we
probably should go somewhere else to eat
you know
yeah but he didn't break and tell him no
look that's just the whole thing you
just
no i went with it so you never
philadelphia
did you get to spots where you were you
want to just tell the world like no i'm
i have this military history i'm acting
i'm doing
no not only did that at my daughter's
school i went up there a few times
i'm a i'm a cub scout leader you know oh
my god
the cub scout leader is waving the iraqi
flag on television so i have to go up to
schools and
tell them i'm just you know an actor i'm
their father
this is just a character i portray and
it didn't really help but
you know my elder started in chair and
uh she
you know went with everything and my
youngest daughter was a fighter he'd
stand and
fight for me and she'd come home
sometimes a black guy or they'd give her
[ __ ]
he was but she'd fight back he fought
back did you ever physically call my
father that you know yeah did you ever
have a physical problem with somebody
out
well not not too much you know we uh i
got to philadelphia
next day after i won the title from the
ultimate puke and we
and i got there and j strombol was the
uh road agent and he said have you
talked to your wife today
and i said no is there something wrong
he said no i don't believe so
if he talked to vince and i said no and
he said well you might want to give him
a call we didn't have cell phones so i
find it pay phone i call my wife there's
just a machine and i leave a message and
then i call vince and he just gotten
back from miami he's in the office and
he said uh yeah if you're talking to
your wife and no spoken to your wife
no uh is there a problem no uh
somebody called the wrestling office
this morning said they're gonna kill you
they're gonna kill your family they're
gonna kill me kill my family
blow up our houses blow up the wrestling
office the studio
our cars and i thought i'd take a
precaution and call your wife tell her
get the hell out of the house
you know just in case you know we don't
know yeah so
uh i finally got a hold of my wife and
of course she said i told you this
wasn't a good idea
so you know we kept on going and i
finally got home about
four days later and uh i lived in
connecticut boston connecticut
and i had this house that was hard to
find i loved the the
road because it was dirt and they didn't
have a road sign and when you finally
got to my driveway it was a big windy
thing up the
you could already get a car up there
that's convenient when you're going on
tv as a former military man sympathizing
with the iraqis
yeah the hill and there's a winnebago
i don't know how it got up there and
four gentlemen come walking over
out of a black sedan sedan and they
opened up their uh coats and showed me
their packing weapons
and told me they were going to walk the
perimeter of my property
the four acres 24 7 until they were told
not to
going to take my children to school wow
who got that done what's that who got
that done did you vince
oh he did vince mcmahon yeah wow
he uh says till we're told not to so i
walk in the house of course my wife's
got the rolling pin
in her hand another spatula i gotta look
at
and uh so she said i told you this
wasn't a good idea
and i said i know she said i'm not going
to the grocery store with
a armed guard and my children aren't
going to have an armed guard at their
schools i said i know i know so
i told the guy isn't that great after
all this yeah like you know you're
you're the your your whole life and then
everything you're doing you're getting
everybody pissed off you're ready
and you get home and your wife i know i
know yeah yeah
i got it right honey yes honey uh
where's the garbage when we take the
garbage
so uh anyway we we went along with it
and uh
finally one night in madison square
garden uh
vince's father was still you know around
and uh
he said there's some gentlemen that
would like to talk to you i want to do
this little room
and uh they were the fbi and they said
uh we get so many
we don't know if you know this but we
get so many death threats and
problems with you that we were wondering
if you would consider wearing a
bulletproof vest
wow we have this new style that is mesh
you you won't even know you've got it on
but we think we should take a precaution
like just in your day-to-day life
right wow yeah and you said yes just
basically wrestling they said
oh for when you go out to the ring and
stuff so you're the kids you got shot in
the scene did it scare you
well they didn't know i just didn't want
to wear it you know i i've had
bulletproof vests on you know
for most of my military career and
they were bulky but these were pretty
nice i wore it
for about a month and then i just i quit
wearing it and they would have to take
me on an airplane
uh without any other talent superstars
and i would always uh walk down the
plane i wouldn't go through the terminal
and they'd have a
car and escort take me to the hotel or
to the arenas
but it was worth the investment because
the payoff was going to be so big yeah
it was such a big thing how many years
did that happen for
we did that uh we did it up until the
the war really escalated and they were
losing lives oh okay vince and i just
sat down and said
let's let's end it last for my country
back
because people are losing their lives
and you did it for about eight months
right
i mean it kind of ended in summer
way to uh wrestlemania and uh the worst
part about it was that we
we got there and and they told vince you
got to secure the
coliseum it's going to be about three
four million dollars
and he said i'm not doing that so we
ended up going
you know into the 18 000 seat uh uh
you couldn't do 100 4 000 after that
that was the heartbreak of it all yeah
because it would have been too much
money to secure it yeah all that people
say too like i mean
in hindsight people say that part of it
was that business was not as good
as you guys thought it might be because
people were legitimately offended and
didn't want to be
a part of it did you think was that part
of it or not
we did the biggest pay-per-view and had
that record for many years
i see until it was broken of course but
yeah uh no weep
so there was that interest in seeing you
finally get your ass cap
yeah well the fun part about is uh we
we go to the match and they have all you
know uh regis philbin is a special ring
announcer and
and alex treveck is a time keeper and
willie nelson's gonna send
god bless america and donald trump is in
the front row with marla
and and uh all these people that i know
you know uh they wouldn't even talk to
me
wow they were into it so much that they
they started you and um i'll never
forget regis just walked over to me and
you're bad you're bad sergeant
started berating me and how'd you
finally break it how did you finally go
all right we're done with this because
people are really getting killed over
there so how did you find it
and did you worry that you would never
be able to be a good guy ever again
vince told me from the from the
beginning he said
your uh your fans will always love you
and they'll always bring you back
that's a lot of faith yeah a lot of
faith in you especially from that
match we talked about the ally fight
you'll never lose them you know you
always have them i don't care if you're
80 years old a pot belly you can't walk
they're gonna cheer for
you because you entertain them and you
show them you're a tough sound [ __ ]
so uh we decided to do the uh let's go
for the country back
idea went to all the monuments all over
the country and
one night in um some town in
pennsylvania
uh being gene out doing a promo vince
says go out and
and do a uh i want my country back promo
for me
we didn't have scripts or anything and
we were all ad-lib back then so i go out
there and i start
trying to talk i want my country back
people are booing and
drowning me out so finally i took the
microphone and i
started saying god bless america and uh
got kind of teary teary voice and i was
actually
uh sad you know and uh people
stood up with their lighters and sang
the song with me and
applauded and gave me a standing ovation
i walked back and
go through the curtain and vince is just
shaking his head
i can't believe that you did that in
that that short of time that you got
those people back
turned him yeah he said you're teamed up
with hacksaw against
the iron sheik and nikolai volkov in the
next hour
why don't we turn on the x ah
because he saw it he saw the loud and he
wanted you to go back
and do it all over again i said okay
he goes
how did you uh so after wrestlemania you
when you start going into the summer and
just get to the tail end of this
you know evil sergeant slaughter thing
you added
a man named uh uh colonel mustafa
to your yeah to your regime and that was
actually the iron sheik
what was it like uh partnering up
with the iron sheet we've met the iron
yeah before i
never was a uh a fan of that
idea yeah i really didn't want somebody
coming in but vince wanted to
give him some work i guess he missed
owed some money or whatever and
and health felt sorry for him want to
give him some work and
the knees if you go back and watch those
matches the knees aren't what they used
to be on the sheik he can't
actually take bumps right like he can't
really do anything because you can see
him kind of walking on
right like some kind of fake knees right
you know what i mean
so he's not uh he's not in the best
shape in the world no and so we
you know we we started this uh triangle
of terror
you know general adnan journal mustafa
certain slutter
and uh we got to where we went to a
summerslam at madison square
garden match made in heaven match made
in hell
macho man married miss elizabeth the
same night
so uh i'm getting ready to get my outfit
on and here comes vince
takes me into the shower got a little
problem so what
he goes warriors holding me up i said
what do you mean that's 500 000 cash
before he wrestles or he's not wrestling
so warrior comes to vince i'm not going
out there unless you give me 500 000
right now and what's cash
cash jesus so i said well we're gonna do
because i'm gonna pay him
but he's finished he's fired you know
but get let's do the match
so i said okay so there's the uh
mustafa and i said okay i'm gonna throw
a warrior out on the floor you jump down
and break his leg for him
and this goes no no no
no i don't need a lawsuit on him but she
could have done it
if we had the match she could have
broken the leg though if nobody had
stopped him probably
yeah wow so he got this 500 000 k was he
fired right after that yeah
and did he ever come back oh yeah
i was really shocked that he got in the
hall of fame myself but uh
you know uh he's there and uh you know
that's the way the business is did you
just like him
no i don't i never disliked him i always
had great matches with him we made money
together he was
kind of ac dc a few times you know he'd
be on planes with him and he'd be in a
really foul mood or
or whatever but donald dapie was really
a
nice kind guy and and worked hard and
did whatever he had to do
you know get the business done and i
mean the story is that he got fired
literally immediately after the match
right yeah that's amazing well
this said that that's not the worst part
i said what could be worse he goes
he wants to be introduced first
he wants the first pop i said you're
kidding me and that's what really bugged
me
yeah that was the worst part about it so
anyway uh we
i finally had my last match with uh the
ultimate uh warrior
in uh orlando and it was a cage match
and uh in our business you know
a lot of times you connect when you
don't
not really want to hurt somebody but
sometimes you really do
and every night it was like that with
ultimate warrior that puke you know he
he would uh give you a clothesline and
you'd see stars
and so on the last match i stopped at
this uh
market and uh i get this piece of
vegetable and
general adnan says what are you doing
with that and i said you'll see so we
have our match and
about about five minutes into the match
he hits me with a clothesline and i had
this potato in my
my uh outfit and i threw it up in the
air and it started bouncing all around
and in our business if you hurt somebody
it's called a potato
so it's bouncing all around the ring big
idaho potato
and he stops in his tracks and he's
looking at it
and he's looking up the cage on top of
the
you know cage so that how did he get in
here then he looked down at me and of
course i'm
i'm moving my body on a laugh he grabs
that potato and tries to
stuff it in my mouth
was laughing i never heard him laugh
before and uh
so when he got injected into the hall of
fame the night of wrestlemania i tried
to find him and i
because i stopped before the uh
the show and i got another potato and i
was gonna
give it to him as a gift and uh i
couldn't find him couldn't find him
finally i went by a room and he's doing
a promo all night
and he and he stopped doing the promo
and go sergeant slaughter
and i held up the potato and he came
running at me you son
started talking about it and did the
promo and
it was a lot of fun what was your
relationship like with andre andre was
good
good he lived in ellerbe uh north
carolina i live in north carolina right
now but i used to
live there a lot more and uh he would
always have a little party
once in a while and he had this house
that was made for him
giant's house his gazebo was probably
the size of most people's homes
all the doorways were 15 you know feet
high and he had a
like a double king put together and
chairs were made for him and
and uh if andre liked you you were fine
if he didn't like you it was a
pretty rough night they said he didn't
like john stud he hated johnson
hated john and john stud was uh
terrified
he was he was terrified of him i i once
a while i
have john in my car we'd be traveling
and he talked about it
i almost get tears in his eyes so i
don't know why he doesn't like me
i said because you're trying to slam him
you know he doesn't want to be slammed
so uh they're like no it's just a it's a
business we're just
we're just all working together no
doesn't want to no not andre
but he would but he would try to i think
they said he would try to put a hurting
on him when he oh yeah
yeah and andre if he was in a good mood
you're fine
right you know one night i got him and
he'd been on the road came back from
japan
a little town in new jersey people were
coming out of the woodworks
and i come uh to the to the arena and
andre is not there yet his plane's late
finally uh the rep uh one of the guys
said just go out he's on his way
go rile up the people when he's here
i'll send the referee
okay so here comes the uh referee
he looks at me you're in for a good time
what do you mean andre just got off the
plane and and he's in a great mood
you know so here he comes
and uh i get him in the ring and he used
to kind of play around with me and
so i i got him in a front facelock and
he's got this hair
like a lion you know and i i get him in
his front face lock and
of course we we put some pressure on it
pretty heavy
a lot of times just to kid around
with some of the guys we like and uh
so i tell the referee lift his tell ask
if he wants to give up you know
give up to the sarge so the referee
picks up his paw and he drops it down
and
and uh there's no no movement so it
lifts it up again i said ask him if he
wants to give up
and down goes the paw again and all of a
sudden i looked at the referee and
i said to myself something's not right
and all of a sudden
audrey andre fell asleep so tired from
the trip that he
he fell asleep now i'm trying to wake
him up
we've only been in the match five
minutes so i'm hitting on the back and
finally wakes up and now he's mad at me
so he starts chasing him up oh yeah like
a grizzly bear
and uh i started running around the ring
he's coming after me i jumped over the
top rope he'd come over the top run
around finally i headed back to the
dresser he just left yeah i ran around
the the locker room
uh the lockers and he's chasing me
around
and i said what do i do arnie scolding
was the road agent back then and
he said i don't know kid he's got a
cigar i don't know kids
so i i saw the the kid private uh
daniels who used to
right uh drive my uh camouflage limo i
said get the car ready he said uh
the car is he gets the car ready so i
run around running around
andre still follow me i see the exit
door i hit the exit door and
perfect timing there's my camouflage
limo the back doors open i
fly into it and off we go and i look
back and
there's andre that's so funny next day
he got got a hold of me but he did get
home
fun stories so yeah he was quite a drink
right here too did you ever go drinking
with him
oh yeah yeah he he could put him down
yeah they said he would [ __ ] really
pound uh pound beers i mean his hand was
bigger than a beer can we yeah yeah he
would he didn't drink out of a glass of
he just drank the bottle of wine you
know right let me yeah i'm gonna have a
couple wines that means two bottles yeah
yeah
but he was a great guy good man when you
uh uh
later on you were back in the wwe again
as like a commissioner type after you're
done wrestling you're just the authority
figure there
right and you know when you would talk
and you would do these promos and
whatnot
sometimes when you would be animated
you'd spit a little bit
when you spoke right you know that would
happen on your bike
he really did he left a hawker so
they did this bit where sergeant
slaughter is talking to
triple h and shaw michaels who were
young guys at the time and they
interrupt
sergeant talking did you say hang on one
second and they put on
these glass helmets like masks that have
windshield wipers
yeah and they go okay go ahead and they
turn their windshield wipers on while
he's talking
how do you not break and go like
that's the funniest [ __ ] i've ever seen
in my life how do i how do i stay mad at
this
it was the funniest thing i've ever seen
because i didn't know what's happening
yeah they had a we had scheduled to have
this promo
and uh they tell you how much time
you've got when you go out there
and uh so i i get into the ring and i'm
i'm the uh commissioner as you said
and i'm like the sheriff at the okay
corral with no
laws you know i didn't have i couldn't
tell anybody to
do anything really because they won't
listen to me anyway
here's uh you know degeneration x and
shawn michaels triple h and uh
china and so uh there's this paper bag
like you said in and they didn't tell
you in advance what was in the bag
they didn't know about it it's helpful
so i started you know
be rating them and tell them what's
going on and this is the way we do it
you know commissioner slaughter said so
and uh so all of a sudden there's a
whole lot sir just like you said hold on
hold on and he
reached in his bags got these like
plastic welding helmets
with a clear face and they pushed the
button and his damn windshield wipers
started going
well it took everything i had not done
it's probably one of the most classic uh
promo things
that ever took place and but we we just
we would try to do those things of
course we try to have fun and
you know try to make it to the left
especially live television i mean
yeah there's no fixing it you know it's
like when you're watching saturday night
live and all of a sudden
an actor starts laughing and starts
breaking that's coming up or
or something surprises them and they
they just go out of character it's just
it was fun by the way you'll be able to
uh meet the sarge
yourself uh uh he'll be part of
wrestlemania access here in new york
it's going down
april 4th through april 8th it's going
to be sergeant slaughter
and all the other wwe superstars past
present everybody will be there
it's at the brooklyn it's at brooklyn
pier 12 in brooklyn new york it's
new york it's april 4th through april
8th so you get your tickets you get
pick your session or whatever that's on
ticketmaster as are
tickets for wrestlemania 35 which is
going down sunday april 7th
at metlife stadium it's a whole week
long about celebration
and fun and the wrestlemania access is
just
a great time you me like you said you
meet the uh the superstars of today and
the legends and
get photos with them autographs
they used to have a thing where you
could announce a match
with somebody that uh does that like a
michael cole
sure i'm not sure if they still do those
types of things but they have a lot of
interactive fan experiences uh as you
said
memorabilia and uh the biggest display
of
wwe memorabilia in one room or one
under one roof yeah it's amazing you
can't wait to see you were there a
couple years ago
when we were in orlando see what's all
on there yeah
it surprises me every time i i see
everything that's uh being uh
sold and and uh available for the uh
wwe universe too you know you're you're
right you had a rivalry with jim
norton's favorite wrestler of all time
well i was a bob backlund fan at one bob
beckley
yeah bob and i uh i uh you ever see him
doing the knee walk
he's doing the uh the knee walking oh
yeah
you like anymore he was doing he was
doing the uh
step test harvard's step test that we
used to do in the marine corps
and so he said he was gonna do it for an
hour and it was going on all the while
the matches were going on in allentown
pennsylvania what's the step that just
walk up and down
up and down one step uh then you go up
with the other foot
and you just go back and forth for you
know he goes for an hour or two hours
you know
it just uh never stops and uh it's in a
a certain position you have to do it up
in a upright position
and uh so he uh about 55 minutes
or 52 minutes into it i decide he's not
doing it right
so i go out and uh i start pre-rated him
and he's still doing the test and
finally i'd do something to distract him
and because he's going for a record
of amount of time to to do this and uh
so i
get him mixed up and he has to stop so
he gets mad at me he jumps in the ring
after me and i started
uh beating with my uh riding crops my
swagger stick and i welted the back his
back
like uh no tomorrow you whipping bob
bakland that's right
you remember oh i certainly do i was
actually thinking of that as you're
talking
i remember this step and i remember you
whipping bob backlit yeah
yeah and what he uh when he got his
hall of fame acceptance uh speech
he uh walks over up behind the podium
walks over
where i am and he goes and you sergeant
slaughter i still
hate you my daughter hates you my wife
hates you
all my family and neighbors hate you but
we had a health match
[Laughter]
well uh it's just great yeah it's been a
pleasure man don't forget wrestlemania
access
at the brook at brooklyn pier 12 april
4th through april 8th
wrestlemania 35 is april 7th they're
doing the hall of fame there's
everything going
on ticketmaster for all your tickets uh
to the whole weekend i'm sure jim and i
will be doing a whole bunch of stuff
associated with
you know we're gonna be at the uh
barclays center also for uh
raw absolutely and uh nxt takeover uh
hall of fame will be there yeah
smackdown
and the smackdown live yeah it's all
going to be at the barclays center
i can't wait i can't wait it's my
favorite weekend of the year thank you
so much
underscore sergeant slaughter push-ups
for you guys
you're dismissed by the way underscore
sgt slaughter on twitter
is is jim norton as many times as you've
brought up maggots
is jim norton the human being that most
resembles what a
real maggot might look like i think he
would look good in a cobra clutch
i do too i do think you ought to put it
memoir i think so i think okay
yeah let's do it yeah so the sarge is
going to put jim norton
in the cobra clutch further away
right right so the sleeper hold gets
locked on
i like the gym prepares to go to sleep
so the cobra clutch was invented to work
on both
this side and that side okay jim tell me
if you can feel that it would be
effective
oh god yeah i already put it on yeah
yeah yeah that's the cobra clutch oh you
can
how does it feel when it gets a little
tighter it feels very unpleasant
yes i am why indeed the pain in your
forehead is popping
he's choking me he's a strong son of a
[ __ ] is sergeant slaughter still quite
strong
oh my god giant marine hands that's
awesome
[ __ ]